[Music]
thank you very much for being here and
tell us about your current work at
Airbus okay well I'm working on future
missions at Airbus and these are future
space missions which going in all sorts
of directions some of them are to do
with astronomy going to other planets as
well but others are looking at our own
planet looking at providing information
on the state of our planet on climate
change carbon dioxide in our atmosphere
the changing forests around the world so
it's a real mixture between you know the
science that is out there and the
science which is supporting
understanding our planet what are the
breakthroughs that you're most excited
about all that well you know it's
probably more about how to deal with the
huge amount of data that we are
generating whether it's data on the
universe or data on on the earth and to
be able to use that effectively I mean
this is something that affects so many
different areas of life these these
these days but it's for sure effects are
stealing with satellites in orbit around
the Earth or going to other other
planets because they're generating vast
amounts of data and we want to use the
information access that information and
use it in the most effective way what
are the ethical challenges
well there's surely practical challenges
about collecting and organizing data but
what are the ethical challenges that you
encounter in a project like that
um I think it's it's ensuring that what
we're doing is actually connected to the
reality of decision-making it's all very
well to be watching our planet develop
doing interesting things storing away
the data on as I said things like how
forests are developing or changing or
how carbon dioxide is being emitted in
different parts of our of our world it's
important that that work is not done in
some engineering or scientific bubble
but that it is actually got a real
meaning for us for our decision-makers
and for the information we put to use of
at our planet so how do you create a
system of process or an organization
that achieves that well I think you had
to be aware of how things are done
already that you the new boy on the
block these clever stuff from space
actually recognizes the effort that's
been put in whether it's through
organizations like the United Nations or
or other fora and that you are plugging
in with the people who've been trying to
do this using tried and tested methods
and trying to influence governments and
trying to get things changed in the way
we're managing our our planet so that is
where I would say the the ethics kind of
comes into it
okay can we talk about one specific
future mission to do it space travel
yeah okay so bull question how likely is
it that we'll find life on Mars I can't
give you any probabilities the reason
for that is we only know of one set of
life as it were that's what we find on
earth and as far as we know today or
everything we know on earth that's
living has one common ancestor that
doesn't mean that life didn't evolve
multiple times but all it means is that
what we can see today what remains today
that we can detect all has a common and
system now that gives me no basis for
understanding the probability of finding
life anywhere else but we can speculate
a little bit about what helped in the
conditions on the early Earth with the
evolution of life the start of life and
we can start to chip away at the problem
by looking at conditions on other
planets like Mars like the the moons of
Jupiter or moons of Saturn like looking
into I mean incredibly looking into the
atmospheres of planets around other
stars even so we can take some logical
steps but I can give you no
probabilities because we have only found
life once what lessons learnt from space
travel exploration and science can be
applied back home there are obviously
technologies which are applicable in
what we do and I tend to mix up quite
deliberately the work that I do looking
outwards into the universe with the work
I do looking back towards the earth
because so many of the technologies are
very much the same
are there things we can we can learn
I've I've seen scientists developing
sophisticated instruments for the
detection of maybe biochemical processes
on the planet Mars which actually have
real applicability on earth we'll
commercial applicability for the way in
which solvents can be applied to
different problems because they've had
to think so much out of the box to do
something so cleverly on the surface of
Mars with so few resources on a
spacecraft which is so far away that
having solved that problem you know you
can bring that back to earth to think
about some of the things you would do
with that equipment back on back on
earth
things like almost sniffing sniffing for
evidence of diseases let's say so if
you've got something that she's sniffing
very carefully for gases and things on
another planet its applicability on the
earth to health check-ups things like
that suddenly it's so it's it's an
interesting connection because you've
had to solve such a difficult problem in
space what are the values that guide
your work personally or have guided your
career up to this point I think to me to
be honest it's mainly the excitement and
what we're doing and the the the impact
the fact that through the work that I
see doing led by scientists and actually
put in place by engineers like my
colleagues at Airbus it's actually
building things which are adding to our
knowledge both fundamentally about what
this universe is that we've come into
being with some of the big questions
which we still haven't sold about life
and also about how our own planet
functions the amount of information we
are building up which is giving us a
better understanding of just how our own
planet functions
I find that hugely hugely motivating
have concerns about climate change
affected the aerospace industry
yeah I absolutely they they they have I
mean in in in my case very particularly
because I'm in the world of being able
to contribute to the understanding of
climate change and that's kind of kind
of unique and that's fantastic
but of course industry the aerospace
industry has to deal with climate change
as as a contributor to it and as
organization which has to deal with the
impacts of it
so any big industrial organization has
to face up to the fact that it's it's
infrastructure will be affected in the
future by climate change and any
industry which has got an element to do
with Transport in my case it's to do
with aircraft Airbus has to deal with
the fact that it is also a contributor
to to climate change so it's a very
interesting complex sort of situation
for the aerospace industry
how is Airbus going about reviewing its
contributions to carbon emissions and to
climate change well it's doing a lot of
work at the moment on non hydrocarbon
fueled planes now that will not be a
solution to everything but for certain
classes of travel having electrically
powered our planes battery-powered
planes actually is a workable solution
so it's something which has really sort
of come to the fore this year is
starting to be to be different
demonstrated and rolled out so I think
that's that's one of the ways in which
it's responding but some of the
fundamentals are still about burning
hydrocarbons and what's the timeline for
that project for the the new non-hodgkin
based but I can't speak for for the
aircraft part of a very versa so that's
a huge enterprise but we rolled out
demonstration things at the Paris Air
Show this year so this year is a big
year for telling the world about the
potential of non-typical fuel based
planes
and what a airbus has plans for the
future I mean as head of future missions
for the first to go to but what maybe
what are you most excited about they
have us is going the pipeline I I think
it's it's a it's a kind of combination
of things it's about the long term
operational contributions that
spacecraft are now making we're building
spacecraft which will be operating now
contributing to weather services climate
services between now and the 2040s this
is not these are not simple experimental
missions these are things which will be
part of our infrastructure for decades
to come
but at the same time trying to look at
new ways of doing things looking at how
you can use if you like cheaper smaller
ways of doing things to demonstrate new
techniques very quickly to to take new
ways of sensing the earth or looking
into space helping astronomers it's that
mixture which i think is very exciting
now great and when do we make it to Mars
what do you mean by wing this is the big
question when there's one when does when
will someone or when will a human make
it to Mars probably part two when will
yeah you know when we're looking we'll
make it tomorrow okay I think that's
that's quite tricky to to answer we've
got some fantastic and really important
robotic missions lined up to go to Mars
ones which are going in the very near
future I get some arse looking for signs
of past or present life that is due to
be launched next year in 2020 and then
missions which will actually bring back
bits of the planet Mars and that's
really important because if you can
bring things back and put them in
earth-based laboratories you can as as
techniques improve on earth over the
decades you've got bits of that planet
to to to analyze in detail so that will
be very important
the next step humans to Mars well I've
got my personal concerns about that
because Mars I think is a very precious
place whether or not it has any signs of
life on it
and I would think I feel that humanity
needs to think very carefully before it
tries to send astronauts to the surface
of Mars of course it makes the idea of
exploration a lot easier certainly today
an astronaut can be much more flexible
than a machine can but I'm not saying
machines are catching up quite quite
fast but you're right I mean it's a it's
it's a it's a kind of imperative people
do want to explore they do want to put
human beings on other planets but I
would be loath to put a date on on that
I see that as being something a long way
into the future it is very difficult to
land on Mars it is very difficult to
take off from Mars this is a far more
difficult Enterprise than even going to
the moon was at the end of the 1960s do
you think exploration as a word puts a
bit of a gloss on there and it is in
fact a form of colonization no I don't
think at the moment I think exploration
is what it it says is it's a kind of
both at a personal level and the
excitement go and explore and I think
that's that's intrinsic in so many of us
linked with a kind of a political will
to demonstrate capability and to plant
flags I think it's so that that kind of
combination is is what it's about
so yeah I call it its exploration but
with with various motivations for it and
what would happen if with this mission
in 2020 we do find life you know where
if and when the Queen dies there's
operation London Bridge and it all sorts
of things that rolled into place across
the media in politics is this is there
something similar in place for if if we
find life like what happens
I think it's really interesting because
if we do find signs of life or past life
I mean it's likely to be extremely
primitive these are not going to be
little green men that we find on on Mars
so I think everyone has to ask
themselves how long would the media
excitement last and there would be
excitement I'm sure they would but would
it last very long before it's replaced
by you know some other story I'm I'm
slightly depressed to think about that
but I fear that that would be the case
in the scientific world yes it would be
hugely exciting but to everybody else
I'm not quite social that's either thank
you well so much for your time
you're very welcome for more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI
TV
you